the actress who played tokyo had such an
emotionally intense time filming she
suffered serious physical pain as a
result money heist itself is an intense
series so it's no surprise the
experience on set for the actors would
be just as wild from not knowing what
would happen to their characters more
than two episodes ahead to filming in
three different countries the stellar
crew managed to successfully bring a
remarkable final season to life
the actors wearing the signature red
jumpsuits felt like they were wearing
skin and it was a pretty moving
experience for both the actors and their
characters
the suit is highly symbolic as a
representation of what the gang means
for the stockholm actress esther acebo
the jumpsuit represented courage and
struggle for monika within the world of
money heist the suit was a symbol of
their work and all that it took to earn
a place in the ganges
putting on the jumpsuit was a major help
in getting the actors into character and
ready to tell the story as well
manila actor belen questa felt the
symbolic suit was like an adventure
600 of the suits were actually used
throughout the series and really became
an icon for the show
the fifth season had loads of prep and
promo to do so while some days they were
filming other days it was all about
photoshoots and getting the marketing
materials up to par this is no small
task since while taking the photos the
actors made a total mess of the set and
often wound up breaking props in the
process the people who cleaned
everything up had a pretty major task in
front of them by the end of it all
pedro alonso also known as berlin made
his way into the marketing shoot for the
series only to wreak a bit of havoc the
actor mostly ran around interrupting the
whole thing but the crew was so close
that fooling around was alright every
now and then when they got to see each
other although alonso definitely did
enjoy breaking the rules in this case
though we're not too sure the crew would
have appreciated him breaking a chair on
set
the fifth season is being divided into
two volumes being released a few months
apart the reason for this was that the
writers felt they needed to create a
divide in order to properly wrap up the
series
many of the fans of the show have been
deeply affected by the first four
seasons considering how wild and
dramatic the series is it doesn't come
as much of a surprise
that being said the first volume of the
fifth season tops them all and the
professor and berlin actors felt like it
would affect the emotional stability of
viewers since the first part of the
final season is so loaded with battle
the second volume pulls back on the
fiery action and focuses on the
emotional journey of the characters
making sure to take the proper time to
wrap up their stories in the series the
show was able to take its time in doing
the final season justice since there
were 10 episodes to work with rather
than the typical 8 per season
the final series wound up coming to us a
bit later than anticipated as a result
of the kovid 19 pandemic going through
the realities of living in such a
difficult time affected how quickly the
series was able to be written and going
through the day-to-day was a real
struggle just delaying the whole process
once on the set it meant there was
plenty of testing and masks galore but
fortunately they all still got to hug it
out in the end
ursula aka tokyo and money heist had
quite the emotional time filming the
final season of the show
the actress cried when filming every
single one of her scenes for season five
the emotion was so intense she actually
felt physical pain in her stomach
it's no surprise her reaction was so
powerful since the series itself changed
her career and her character became a
major part of her life
alvaro morte or as we know him the
professor wasn't too sad when the series
came to an end since originally the show
was only going to have two seasons as
the second season came to a close the
actor went through preparing to let go
of the role back then so it's been a bit
easier to let go of this time around
with his unique relationship to the show
and role morte was able to really enjoy
getting to have a second chance at the
role and just appreciated that the
journey got to continue actress
pelenquesta found herself in a similar
situation
deeply appreciating the moments she was
working and recognizing how special
certain scenes were she was constantly
reminding herself to be grateful for the
whole experience as she said farewell to
the show
the production company might be called
vancouver media but the series was
actually filmed in various spots in
europe the final season was filmed in
denmark portugal and of course the place
where it all happens
spain the capital madrid was where most
of the filming actually took place
actors in series don't always get all
their scripts at once but often they
will have some idea as to what would
happen with their character's storyline
however the actors of money heist didn't
actually get that much insight the
actors only ever knew what would happen
to their characters two episodes ahead
this meant the writers got to make
adjustments to the scripts as filming
went along allowing the series to really
flow and have a wild feel to it the team
was often writing right up until the
very last minute
an awful lot of time is spent in and
around the bank of spain but the actual
building never makes an appearance in
the series the crew wasn't even allowed
to go to the bank of spain to get
references to remake the set so they
went with their imaginations to create
the interior we see which was a fully
built set in a studio
as for the outside shots we see the
building we're actually looking at is
the spanish national research council
since the royal mint of spain wouldn't
give the go ahead to film any exterior
shots there
carlos diaz has been responsible for the
costumes throughout the series the
variety of the styles and energies of
the characters offered diaz a really
rich experience since he got to explore
very individual looks for the different
actors as well as then bringing them all
together again with the signature red
jumpsuit
the reason the cast members are all
nicknamed after cities is of course to
help keep their identities unknown when
they're in action however the fact that
they were named after cities
specifically was inspired by someone's
t-shirt on set the shirt had tokyo
written on it and after contemplating
different options including planets the
team felt like it was a sign and it
wound up being the perfect tool to help
mislead anyone onto the characters in
the show as well
netflix is actually making a money heist
immersive experience in locations around
the world the team is casting actors to
perform live shows that would begin
launching in 2021 these productions
would offer fans and people new to the
show the chance to be part of the
robbery story experience since once a
ticket is purchased the audience member
becomes part of the family and story as
for spin-offs the plan was to wait until
after the final season wrapped and
premiered before committing to anything
else but the idea is definitely being
considered by multiple people involved
money heist has certainly been a ride
and became a totally unexpected success
the passion the cast and crew had
everyone from the directors actors
costume designers to the creator is
admirable and a definite component of
what made the series so special we're
definitely eager to experience the
heisting up close and personal with the
immersive experience